believe that this is my seventh year of
pardoning a turkey
time flies even if turkeys don't
we should also make sure everyone has
something to eat on thanksgiving
of course except the turkeys because
they're already stuffed
so somehow that very unfunny man now has
his own sketch comedy show on netflix
that's right the former president and
first lady are producing a show called
the g word
which is expected to be loosely based on
an anti-trump book about the supposed
chaos during the transition in 2016.
it's not only the comedy series no one
in america is not asking for
it's also just more competition for my
next guest who is joining me
now jeff dunham whose new comedy
special completely unrehearsed last
minute pandemic holiday special
premiered tonight on comedy central
congrats about that
thanks lisa so jeff this is really
something that you know we need more of
which is
anti-trump bias there's there's not
enough of that right now
yeah if walter lisa you didn't introduce
neither that's fine and thanks for
having me on the show
i got a question for you before we get
into the obama thing so
sitting in for laura over thanksgiving
is this like a career move or did you
lose a bet
well i would say a career move but i and
i'm sure the people who hate me would
say other things
yeah you know absolutely obama sketch a
comedy show
i just i honestly don't understand that
there's the dignity of the office
there's the 72 million people you know
that voted the other way
uh this year so i i i really bewilders
me but did you know lisa did you know
this that
obama actually wanted to be our opening
act in our comedy central special this
time did you know that
why i hope he said no because he's not
very funny well
we didn't say no the secret service said
no because they wouldn't let jeff
stuff them in the suitcase well yeah i
mean that would probably raise some
alarms i would assume among the secret
service
but so here i mean look why the comment
comedians have barely touched joe biden
like i can give you plenty of material
he sat around with kids around him
talking about a guy named corn pop
he talked about when he was a lifeguard
at the pool kids touched his hairy legs
i mean right there
target rich environment why have
comedians not they've barely touched it
i you know it's it's that the castle
culture because it's it's amazing how
comics now uh i used to say that that
stand-up comedy was the last form of
free speech it's not anymore
because you know how it is everybody has
a voice now everybody's on social media
there used to be the sanctity of the
comedy club or the sanctity of uh
you know the live show uh but now um
and i used to say if you were offending
five percent of the audience it was a
good it was a good number because the
five percent that were ticked off
whatever they were mad at the other 95
were laughing at but now unfortunately
that five percent can in your career
with a couple of tweets so it's
it's becoming really difficult now but
so why do you think we've arrived at
this moment though i mean you're talking
about some of the canceled culture we
see
we literally see people go through you
know social media accounts like
five years ago right and try to destroy
someone's career so why
why have we arrived at this point
well i again i think it's the social
media i think that uh everybody has a
voice now and everybody
it didn't used to be that way you didn't
hear from joe schmoe but now joe schmo
can say whatever he wants he can hide in
his basement hide behind his uh
his computer screen and his keyboard and
just say what he wants and so
like tonight my premiere uh my special
premiered and i was talking to the
people that look at this stuff for me
and i said how are the numbers how is it
you know how is uh
what are the reactions reactions are
good and then what percentage of haters
do we have
well there's always haters
right but i do i i don't know the answer
to this and for the people that tend to
lean a little bit right uh yeah there's
no room for you um
it is amazing how it's just like voting
the same thing if you leaned a little
bit right we're gonna
vote for trump you didn't dare tell
anyone it's the same with comics
or anybody in show business right now um
there are many businesses you can't say
i want to make you can't say if you're
leaning right right and i want to make
sure when i play this uh clip for the
audience because i want to make sure
they see it before
um you've got to go so this is from your
new holiday comedy special everyone take
a look
you're not six feet away unsafe cause i
got a little mask on
we want some laughs yeah and we're in
the middle of the terrible pandemic so
let's have a nice chuckle
why do you think we've been staying at
home so much walter says because your
career is over with
so tell me a little bit about your
special and why people should tune in
well this one really was a last minute
special i've been sitting around for for
months and i thought i got to do
something here's when i knew i had to do
something i was in the kitchen with my
five-year-old twin boys and my wife
i picked up a chip clip to make it talk
my boys were on the floor laughing they
thought it was a comedic genius
i thought i got to get out of this house
so we threw this special together
and uh some really good writers we put
it all together we put it on stage i
only thought it up two months ago we
shot it three weeks ago and now it's on
the air
it's aired a couple times already on
your coast and it's going to air in just
a few minutes at 8 o'clock our time here
on the west coast
but i did it because i feel people need
laughs and there's no politics in this
special whatsoever
uh so i've changed that up a little bit
it's for the whole family and i just
think it's
goofy stupid fun yeah i like your show
no well jeff and walter i can't forget
uh you little guy
or i guess old guy you look uh you know
i mean you look kind of young but you
know
all right jeff walter thanks for joining
us